foreign
the issue of child removal in the
Scandinavian region particularly in
Norway and Sweden has become somewhat of
an international spectacle a scandal of
sorts in recent times
78 of the court cases which reach the
European core of human rights have been
lost by Norway in particular the issue
has become so scandalous that there's
even a film coming out called Mrs
chatterbee or Mrs Chatterjee versus
Norway which is due to be premiered on
Bollywood screens this film attempts to
depict the life of a woman whose child
was forcibly removed you see forcibly
removed on bogus grounds illegitimate
grounds unjustifiable grounds
and the trauma that she suffered
thereafter
the issue has become so problematic
that even members of the media the
Norwegian media VG being one of the
mainstreams of Norwegian media one of
the Premier stations said that this is
likely to drag Norway's reputation under
the models ruin brunoway's reputation
today we're going to be interviewing an
affected party who's witnessed these
events firsthand now we are not going to
be identifying this individual because
clearly identifying them could cause all
kinds of consequences in their lives so
we are going to be distorting their
voice and blurring their faces and so on
so that they can tell their story more
freely without cost or repercussion so
you've heard my introduction do you
think what I've said is accurate
it's a quite accurate
there is not enough media coverage about
this and
there should be definitely more coverage
around this topic because it's a serious
matter
and it's affecting many lives in Norway
um I want to go into a little bit about
what happened in your family what you've
witnessed firsthand because firsthand
reports are for us the the important
thing
what is what happened with you like in
your family what did you witness my two
younger cousins were taken from the
child services because they accused my
uncle of being violent a violent father
and a wild husband
and they were taken for
a couple of years
actually saw the family's reaction very
closely since they often were at at our
house they even moved for some time
and I remember
all of them
screaming and crying
and they were emotions like anger and
confusion of why it was happening
because at that time this was unheard of
to us at least
um and even today when I hear
about some of the stories
from other people
I often like want to
I get those flashbacks to that time and
Honkers calls you trauma yes definitely
because when I hear about those stories
I can't even explain how my body reacts
I just want to fight everyone in the
system I want to shout I want to scream
I get really frustrated every time I
even heard about a mother that passed
away because she couldn't bear the
trauma or the pain of being away from it
this happened in Norway this happened in
Norway a couple of years ago
okay just going back to your own
situation you said that you remember
when whatever happened happened when the
tell us a bit about first of all what
happened how the children were removed
from your your uncle and your auntie
and then what you actually witnessed
thereafter
I was 14 at that time around 14 so I
didn't quite understand what had
happened exactly that day
but the children were removed from the
kindergarten that day they got the
message the child services received the
message
from the workers at the kindergarten
and nobody got to even say alas goodbye
anything they would just
they were taken and I just remember that
that night the parents of the children
were at our house and I my mother took
me upstairs and she tried to explain to
me the situation
but as I said I didn't quite get it
um but a couple of days later when I
didn't get to see my cousins that's when
I think I understood that okay they're
they're not no longer living with their
parents how old are the children
so kindergarten age around three four
two kids here three four-year-old kids
who went kindergarten yeah and you know
the parents have trusted the
kindergarten to look after their child
for them
the kindergarten now for whatever reason
decides to hold the children back social
services or their Protection Services
hold the children back and not give them
back to the children to the parents
then you're seeing the parents react in
these very emotional justifiably
emotional ways can you tell us a bit
about how they how they reacted what was
their emotional reaction
all of us were crying all the time
prior to this happen
to meet each others we used to have
Gatherings at our our grandmother's
house because they used to live with my
grandmother and we used to have
celebrations there and after this
happened everything felt like it just
died we we didn't celebrate some big
occasions
nobody made jokes anymore
the whole mood the whole family was
shaken after this happened and even
today when I came before I came here I
talked to my uncle over the phone and
you can hear in his voice how
traumatized he is you can hear his voice
is shaking he couldn't complete his
sentences
every time we discuss what had happened
the whole family just
they don't know how what to say because
we are still in shock many of us are
still in shock that this even happened
so many people will be thinking now well
if they were to remove the children
there must have been some real cause for
this they must have this man must have
been maybe sexually abusive maybe was he
an individual who harmed the children or
were the parents individuals who harm
the children is there any evidence of
this or what was their
um actual justification for taking the
children away well there were all
assumptions first of all because they
claim that my uncle was violent with his
wife and with his children that they
sold bruises on the wife's face and the
children's body and
they said well at that time my cousins
both got those chickenpox that's what
they're called and they thought that
those were secret marks that my uncle
did
so as a result of that they decided
we'll then take these children away
what's the reason
there was no discussion about if that
was the case I mean even if they did
think that that the children were to be
given custody to the mother for example
and not to the father nothing like that
that the mothers since she is from our
homecoming or our home country they
thought that she doesn't have any
relatives here except for her in-laws so
they thought that she couldn't stand up
for herself she couldn't get a divorce
she couldn't they wanted her to get a
divorce so that then they would give her
back her children so blackmailing do
what as we say and they will get your
children back
so this seems to be a violation of all
kinds of Rights here like you know what
will be considered in the European Union
for example is human rights or even on
the feminist ground what would be
considered as women's rights so have you
seen for example
go on the feminist question have you
seen any women talk about this issue um
women's rights movements have has anyone
from the women's rights movements really
talked about this issue and pushed for
it to be changed
I haven't I haven't seen any woman
raising her voice for
talk to talk about this issue no women
here because those rights you're talking
about they're only
um for the privileged people they don't
they don't account for the
non-privileged people or the ethnic
people
throughout there is this um lady
um her name is tundeo
to thundail yeah who's it who's a human
rights activist who's who's trying to
you know talk about these things but
she's doing on human rights grounds and
I'm just really surprised that no way of
country is as it claims to be a very
civilized country where the Peace Prize
is given and so on
there isn't more action to be taken what
kind of action would you like to be
taken here I wish that they were a lot
more talk about this in the media uh
it's true that there are sometimes when
you read an article that's about a case
where there has been a mistake by the
child services but there is no
consequences they don't face any
consequences that are extreme and in
this profession there is no room for
mistakes you have to choose your
profession if you choose a profession
like this you need to be sure that
you're making the right decisions
because they really can affect the
family
just to be very clear about the
allegations that were being made were
they in your opinion were they true or
were they false they were false
allegations
the thing is that they since they have
gotten their children back they won the
case after two years they got the
children back alhamdulillah they are
living with their parents now
um but the problem is that they have
they haven't received any apology No
Remorse nothing
and it's like to think just to invade a
family's personal space and ruin their
lives take away their peace and then
Show No Remorse no apology
no compensation no compensation nothing
the fact that they've won the case now
within the system is a double-edged
sword of souls because we on the one
hand there's some hope I guess you know
but on the other hand
that is an admission that they were in
the right and the other ones were in the
wrong as this legal admission that okay
these guys weren't doing any of that
stuff and that in fact these people were
blamed incorrectly they were unjustly
treated and the fact that you can have a
child at the age of four years old or
three years old
who is taken forcibly from somebody into
somebody else's custody someone else
raises your own child
and that not even compensation is
granted is incredulous isn't it
it's evil
it's the parents it's their worst
nightmare
and to traumatize them for their lives
they were they have now expanded their
family but before doing that they were
very scared and because they're more
it's more pressure on them now because
of their history with child services now
so it's it's a fearful for their whole
life
and it's no remorse no no apology
nothing at all and it just proves that
how selfish they are it's like they're
really just only viewing it as their job
so it's only their job but they don't
see it as the ethics where are the
ethics where is the moral there is
nothing there is no Humanity in this I
just wanted to ask you right
um you talk about they be removed and
all these kind of things and
families from let's say a subcontinental
Asian background the Muslim children
uh where were they relocated were they
relocated with uh you know foster care
another family and if so were they
Muslims or
so here's the thing not only are they
removing their children from their
parents but they're giving those
children to foster parents who have no
idea of their culture their background
their religion their language my cousins
for instance they were given to a
Norwegian foster foster parents or
Foster family
and they fed them bacon and I remember
my grandmother she was very frustrated
by this and you know elderly people
there all often have health issues and
when she heard this she's diabetic and
we were all very scared for her health
these points are so important that you
choose a family
who have at least at least they can do
is to choose the family
who have the same similar culture at
least the same religion background
religious background that's and they
didn't even do that nothing like that it
was a Norwegian Family Christians I
don't even know their religion but they
were not non-muslims
so just to summarize the point the
children were taken away from
kindergarten because they had bruises on
them okay which could come about from
whatever reason which they apologized
for very often because they realized
that it was something which was
incorrect because the Judgment was
recalled and so the children were taken
away from these Muslim parents they were
put into the care of say these atheists
or Christian parents who are not even
from the same background
who and they didn't have any connection
they didn't even have any
communication with their own parents and
they were given to these people that's
what happened yes no communication with
their parents
um they were given to these people who
as I said they didn't know Haram what's
Halal what's Haram and we even discussed
this in our family that imagine if they
were girls not boys imagine if they were
girls that would have been
way more
um difficult for us to comprehend
because you know for my for the my uncle
and the children's parents they when
they heard about this stuff they felt
very helpless because they couldn't stop
them from doing that because they don't
have any rights anymore they don't have
the custody of their children anymore so
hearing that your your child is doing
that now your child is not following the
religion correctly
that's very disturbing for the parents
it's very disturbing for the viewers I'm
sure as well there you have it folks a
first-hand report
in the Scandinavian region here in
Norway
of an individual who has faced this
matter firsthand and seen the trauma
that has brought to their lives imagine
just imagine a three-year-old and a
four-year-old you might be a mother or a
father you might have brothers and
sisters you yourself watching this
imagine if it was the case that you your
brother your sister your children were
snatched away from you and that you
couldn't see them for years on end
because of some allegations some bogus
allegation which wasn't even compensated
you've missed two years of your
children's life even in the animal
kingdom even in the animal kingdom if
you take away
a child or an offspring from a parent it
would be seen as a great immorality
animal rights issue
going into the wild and doing that this
is meant to be a human's rights issue
Europe is meant to be the Bastion of
Human Rights Norway is meant to be the
country which Awards peace prizes and
the government here
is responsible for the most heinous of
removal of children they've lost 78 of
cases some cases haven't gone to the
human rights courts but they've not even
issued apologies or compensation
there's a scandal of tremendous
proportions
shocking thing
this is something we need to
collectively raise awareness of this is
something which if we don't act now the
children of certain communities which
may be more affected than others here
let's be honest are going to be
continually removed the abuse and the
trauma will proliferate in the
Scandinavian region and that is why it's
important to raise awareness as I say
share this video far and wide
let's make a change in the world I'm
sure we can
foreign